liminality is basically the fourth film
we've produced as part of the dan stone
platform which is our audience
engagement platform for breaking down
barriers of access to contemporary dance
here in Wales so the remit of the
project is create immersive dance films
in the 360 medium we distribute those
films freely to the world's planetariums
and they get screened all over the place
to audiences for free and then we also
tour our own immersive dome out into the
streets of whichever festival or city
waters does 2017 is the UK India year of
culture as a result of that liminality
was conceived as a chance to push our
platform and our creative opportunities
further whilst also building networks
with international collaborators the
exciting thing to us about 360
filmmaking is that we can literally in
an instant jump you from fund view back
to you but your environments changing
and every time your environment changes
like walking into a room you've never
been into before there's this sense of
discovery when you're not having stuff
handed to you on a plate you're in the
middle of the space and it's bound to
you as the viewer to decide what you're
taking in such a unique and interesting
way to present dance in particular and
the fact that you're able to completely
immerse the audience into a different
world is really great and something
really exciting as a coda but to look at
and to work with and you can see how you
can join the dance and the filming
aspect into one to make the whole thing
feel like an experience most of our
cameras are attached on the far end of a
selfie stick or monopods so that there's
as little legs splay and objects
interfering in in
magic of I can look wherever I want it's
kind of ruined when you look down and go
there's a tripod or there's the hand of
the photographer how do you move a
camera or how do you record a sequence
without the crew being in the shot or
the grip equipment that's moving the
camera being in the shot and we took a
few different experimental approaches
and in how we went about that so one of
the systems we use was basically a
radio-controlled car with a special 360
game ball on the top we also employed a
cable cam system so we used the same
stabilizer that we have on the
radio-controlled car and that was
basically a piece of rope between two
trees and then a radio control unit that
enabled us to fly the camera up and down
there was a couple of processes that
we've looked into the drove us down the
route of basically concentrating on
utilizing consumer cameras we're a big
believer that even even though you can
you can definitely get much higher
resolution images off of a multi camera
array there were techniques like
timeslice that we just simply couldn't
do with multiple multiple arrays this
often known as bullet time it it's it's
the process of taking multiple cameras
around the subject and by sequencing up
individual frames from the sequential
positions you're able to basically
freeze a moment or slow down a movement
and change the viewers perspective
around the subject
[Music]
[Music]